yo for me uh being somebody who is a fat
[__] uh respectfully of course to all
the fat [__] out there I always I
always I'm curious cuz you guys are so
good at dropping weight you guys have
figured out weight loss in a way that
most obese men in the world have not
figured out all right how do you drop
like what first of all because I've seen
guys drop like uh like like wild amounts
of weight pretty quickly like what is
the key if you need to make weight and
maybe you you've been [__] up the
wrong food the last week or so how do
you drop weight so fast as a boxer I
think that um it all got to do with
discipline I think discipline is like
the main thing um I mean that's obvious
but that would be you know that's
drinking water drinking water drinking
water is like a huge thing when you want
to cut weight on do you go into like a
sauna and just sweat it out nah I don't
do the sauna but people do that they
people that do the sa but me I I don't
believe in the sa I think that like I I
don't like it I don't like the way it
make me feel after I be feeling like
kind of drink but um I drink water um
and work out work out you got to put
extra layer of clothes on too that was
not the easy answer we were hoping for
drink water and work out everybody yeah
but you got to drink a lot of water it's
not just drink uh two glasses no you got
to drink like see I got this gallon
thing right here yeah you stay you're
staying with the water you drink a
gallon of day more I drink over a gallon
a day wow yeah that's a lot of water you
must have to piss a lot oo definitely do
I'll be waking up in the middle of night
on having P too is it true like
obviously your fight's a couple of weeks
away are you withstanding from busted
nuts at this point yes you're not
beating cheeks nah hell no for sure how
how far out do you like cut off the the
the you know the the the Intercourse I
think I'm like a 4 we typ person wow
good for you man I don't know how like
certain people be saying like I've done
it before yeah 8 weeks8 weeks they do8
weeks strong um shout out to them them
people they tough and do you like feel
the difference cuz you I have heard like
you know like it's like an energy thing
like yeah I feel I feel a difference I I
feel like when I bust I feel like it
make me a little lazy like I'll be in
the ring lazy smart man yeah but when I
like hold it it's like I'm not as lazy
I'm feeling good
could do what I want I got to get your
thoughts uh there was a big fight that
happened this past weekend um what are
your thoughts on the uh the fury uh
fight oh my God man did he steal that
one man I don't know what I was watching
I you watched it yeah I seen some of it
cuz I was sparring at the same time got
you so then I got done and I watched
like the last four rounds but I want to
say I don't know I don't know what I was
watching like I don't know what Tyson
Fury was doing
it didn't make sense to me it didn't
look like Tyson Fury in the ring like it
didn't but he still won but cuz it was a
was it a draw it was a draw right but no
it was he won he won he end okay okay
but it didn't look like him like I I
watched plenty of Tyson FY fights and uh
usually he's punching it didn't look
like he was even throwing punches he was
doing a lot of hugging he wasn't
punching it didn't make sense to me like
it it didn't he didn't look like the
same person to me I wonder like cuz you
always see like I haven't seen so many
people say someone was robbed so much in
a long time like I remember there was um
maybe like a Pacquiao fight like 10 or
15 years ago that I remember it was
there was a lot of back backlash on uh
when I was living in Vegas but it seems
like the consensus is that this guy was
robbed man any close fight they going to
say It's a Robbery yeah so it don't
matter like just because he's like a MMA
person and they they suspect Tyson F to
just wash him um if it's close of course
they going to say it's Ry so I don't I I
ain't watched The First beginning rounds
to really tell you um but all I'm going
to say
is it just seemed like they want that to
be like the narrative so well I mean
look at the end of the day like that
that is something that a lot of people
say about boxing is that they feel like
because it always goes to scorecards
that it there is room for people to get
robbed you know what I'm saying like and
from a Fan's perspective you know what I
mean I'm I'm sure it can be frustrating
to be like that's some bad judges
there's some bad judges out there right
and then there's rematches that people
want to have made and all this [__]
right so I I don't mean to cut you off
before you ask your question but I want
to say um any MMA fighters who uh feel
this though that they could jump in the
boxing ring with a box anybody close to
my weight I would love for y'all to jump
in the ring with me and uh try me out
caror McGregor try me out any of them I
don't care which one it is uh um Cody
Crawley what's the people that's like
there's the guy who's like the Maga dude
who's fighting this weekend uh Cody
Covington I think yeah whatever whatever
whoever it is um that's close to my way
I would love for them to get in R trop
me out well it's crazy cuz the nana new
dude like he like he held his own like I
was expecting him to get smoked for sure
and that's why I would love to show like
it ain't going to go the same when I get
in there I would love to show like no
MMA fighter could get in the ring with
me and even survive have you had anybody
approach you to do anything like that
cuz it seems like that's kind of the the
thing going right now I heard it was
somebody said that um one of the guys
said my name um what's the guy he be
going back and forth with uh Devin too
um I don't know his name I don't know
his name but uh like I said any one of
them dudes want to step in the ring I it
feels like easy money for you it is for
sure but I just want to show them like
you can't jump in no boxing ring with me
and it's going to go that way I promise
you I'm not going to lie to that yeah I
was a little surprised to see that that
fight went went the way it went yeah I
ain't like it I was like damn that's
going to open up the the the can of
worms for everybody to want to come in I
felt like it it was
disrespectful um yo so this is the fight
that uh we're we're getting obviously uh
there's been a lot of I mean everybody's
asked you about obviously whenever
you're going to fight Haney is this
going to happen after this fight is
there any sort of progression in those
talks cuz I think we keep hearing about
the negotiations falling through maybe
he's not serious about fighting you what
what is is is that fight ever going to
get made I would love for the fight to
happen um [__] I y'all can clearly see
that I want the fight yeah like y'all
can clearly see I don't know why like
people try to spin the narratives and
like a lot of people good at social
media so they'll turn the narrative into
something else and 30 other people run
with that narrative but um truth be told
I love to fight like I I I fight anybody
yeah um I jumped in the ring with him
for a reason I didn't just jump in the
ring and do that for no other reason
besides okay let's get let's get the
fight started and and is the is what's
off about it still the split I think
what's off about it is his team like I
don't think I think his team is going to
throw anything out there to uh make sure
the fight don't happen um I don't think
that they want the fight to happen right
now um that's what I heard like from
what I was hearing I'm I'm hearing that
that's what it feels like there's so
many weird politics in boxing that I
don't think people understand if you're
just like a generic boxing fan cuz
you're like well this should be easy
like this guy and this guy they want to
fight this is a big money fight there's
a lot of money to be made but sometimes
like you said there's timing yeah it's
business and that's above everything and
that's how they looking at it they see
it as okay why we fight this big RIS
fighter right now rather than wait a
couple of years where we we could make
more money but yeah they could run it
cuz if they lose to you that's going to
[__] up
that that might [__] up his bag yeah and
then like like like you know it's it's
almost like what happened with um for
people who are like casual boxing fans
it's like Jake Paul losing Y is bad for
business yes right so he has to keep
winning so the fact that he lost to tyur
or Tommy Fury is is is uh was was kind
of bad for business yeah but like I say
him and that one dude well his his
brother and that one dude up they they
stirred up some [__] and that fight was
terrible my only issue it right if
that's the case don't perpetrate as if
that's what you want to do you know
you're perpetrating and acting like that
um this is what you want and um you
talking big but truth be told um you put
me and him in a in a ring where nobody
else can help him there's nobody else
that going to be able to fight for him
what's going to happen like he know deep
down inside that I'm the truth that's
what he know he know he done been the
ring with me several times um he go ask
him like really ask him and tell him to
be honest about me as a fighter um
you'll really hear how he talk and um
honestly I think he's a good fighter but
um I think that his levels